Hi everyone, I'm the Navy's grandson.
dunga team by google launches at
today's episode
Let's see how to use a side menu
with the layout in your android app
19 drug complaint is a panel that displays
the main navigation areas in the
left side over captive is a
panel that is hidden for the most part
of time but exhibiting with the user
pass from left to right with
your hands on the casserole or touch the
epe
if it is available it is easy
identify who will have it three lists
side of the icon that will give the invention
episode that he can click there and
access your drug drug wants with
drug layout and one more important thing
consider deciding and implementing
this wai pattern we need to understand the
cases of use and some considerations
on design in the use of the name of
shannon brown hertha but let's give a
look when using drug drug
for example more than three levels
main navigation
so I only have the various levels of
navigation with views top on my part
mediation it is important to be able to use
Remember drugs if you have
three levels it is recommended that you
uses fixed telephones, for example
they make navigation simpler and easier
fast the sun is already seeing him
the three options he can already click and
easily switch navigation between
different secondary levels of
application content for example has
many categories
I do not feel a certain category in
subcategories you can in a way
Quick select those boos
subcategories and if you put too much up to be
use ends up being lost that much has a
side to the other even using the
tags with utah scroll or very levels
deep navigation in one of the options
you have one of the navigation areas is
very deep and a young man stayed
come back come back and this may end
impairing application skills
and by placing navigation drug it can
direct he chose a level that he
want to go back then use this
investiture as a national guide
the action that makes it very easy but also
has other considerations which is very
important you visit someone's design
to orient well when they are good
recommendations use it is good and as
which I then create navigation drug
using a good first draw and layout
that you will use in this example
free support so you can then
have the layout available in the
previous android
ok then I have to do is declare
a main interface interface of your
activity and having as root
the droid out because it will contain all the
content under its
after that he added a ship then
to the main content of the screen that is
where you will place the flagrante
example with different contents
views and a specific part of the content
navigation drug kelly the panel that goes
be shown
It's an example of him I think we have
here I am using a civil junk
on then we here the main heard the
stockholm layout troller observing the
support we have up to a frame layout
that's where I'm going to put the contents
to be content where I am going to do
the placement of the flagrant and below the
garbage and saw that exactly where you will get the
content number 9 leaving drug
Okay good and how will I treat them then?
clicks on them require navigation
as I gave the example of the list here I
I'm using the interface list
saw item the item click list is for
when I click on one of the items it can
then trigger a specific action that
I know the first thing to create a
fragment you want to display later
use the mg fragment so that it
make the exchange of the content being
displayed by the option that the user
selected our friends then
update the highlight on the list that I
can I give populated feedback where it
is in the position at which moment and of course
close the trolley out good and how can i
do to open and close using a
application icon that is very cool the
applications usually do this so the
eyes already identifies that he can
clicking on the icon opens this code
small screen it goes to
its a customer of your tivit where I
I'll create an action power object
turbo informing him face activity
or who will have that drug or
drug and layout you've created people
because the former ide
the icon to replace the op navigation
The description for the pib is cloud and there
how come it's a classic of a koubek
we have shoulder to icloud that is called
when its completely closed
and a drop that is called when it is
fully open
in this example we are defining the
action bar in accordance with the
open or close the draw and there
so that we can make it
Raining and interacting with the drug
and layout is using 17 illicit drug
so we're going to cause that
they interact well and with that then the
that is, from now on
use another layout in your
application and now try a menu
left side which leaves excellent
browsing your user
remember to arrive at the description of the
where you will have a link that you
official documentation and there will be
a complete example of how you can
implement the drogba navigation launched
android app
Thank you very much and see you next time.